what are we doing movie news movie news
I thought its movie Jews I'm very
prepared
[Laughter]
hello reject nation
Greg Alva here John here sammy gonzales
the Mex awaits from double toe sadaqa
calm is with us today
they talk a lot about movie news and
movie reviews so make sure to go check
them out and make sure to follow Samy
plenty of hot ass pictures over there
yeah I'm telling you guys those bikini
shots are something worth remembering
one might even say that they're pretty
mixolydian second week of April yeah
it'll be a whole two days so first order
of business David Leitch Leitch life
what a terrible last name Nootka really
should get a change latkes Jewish yeah
tasty right movie Jews the week yeah
yeah the week he is confirmed to be the
director of fast and furious Hobbs and
Shaw spin-off film oh boy never again
will he make his own original movie not
one to make our accident somewhere in
the distance you can hear Tyreese
screaming about yeah I gotta get that
video Tyrese upset about this
I feel like the behind-the-scenes of
fast and furious will make a more
interesting movie one day than any of
these fast and furious oh yeah it's to
be oh yeah I really hoped just the Chad
style ski is directing all of his rant
videos patch up their [ __ ] and make Jon
wait for Sammy how do you feel about
this Hobbs and Shawn movie I mean this
franchise prints money so do it the rock
can sell anything to anybody at this
point Jason Jason state Jason Statham
Stefan Jankel
[Music]
at home Jason Statham can also sell just
about anything but to a Dumber audience
and so you put those two together you
got the high-class craziness and you got
the low-class craziness and you make for
one crazy-ass movie well people really
care about this movie yes you think so
yes because the thing is that if this is
less about cars I mean it's almost not
about the cars anymore anyway it's about
them just getting into like ice heists
and all sorts of things like that enter
the cars now yeah like their chemistry
is what made this happen and I feel like
you pointed that out we don't have as
many movie stars we don't have as many
like action stars these are two dudes
who actually can still kind of do that
more so the rock then hasn't Statham
well yeah together I'm sure they know
the rock smash movie that just came out
as a movie with him with it a giant
gorilla mm-hmm and now Jason Statham his
next movie with Warner Brothers is a
giant shark and now they're doing this
time would they team up what would be
the purpose of them teaming up but then
again Fast and the Furious has never
been about the story hey even though
they try to sell like from anywhere even
mortal enemies who killed some of your
team yeah exactly
I'm just excited for the scene where
both the rock and Jason Statham punch a
car at the same time and it flips over
them exactly David Leitch is the kind of
guy who can deliver us that I'm not sure
why David Leitch is the guy who's
becoming like this go-to
director for so many things like atomic
blonde was alright in my opinion
Deadpool - we have no idea how that's
gonna turn out that's from a different
studio yeah and when I think about John
wick chapters
I was liking that and liked it as much
as part one it was still really fun Tom
llamas kind of boring for a lot of it
yeah who did what to is that waitress
now ski ah you know what it doesn't
matter to me if I've got my name's
correct
I feel like The Fast and the Furious
franchise they found something that
works but they also kind of need to
switch it up again and so I feel like a
guy like David Leitch with a very visual
sense like even if atomic blonde wasn't
exactly as thrilling as we all wanted it
to be it still has that visual and that
tonal style that's a really distinct
that was missing from John wick too for
me so for something like this to see him
go to that and to bring that lifestyle
could be cool for something that's kind
of stale to me this franchise you know
that's true that's true
I mean it's faster than that who cares
yeah these movies are getting to the
point where they're not for us anymore
yeah they're for the international
market their family is family
entertainment as long as they're
punching things they could just punch
their way to international fame and
success like they have been so I think
it's cool to rock adjacent sounds some
modern-day Schwarzenegger and like Dolph
Lundgren I hope it turns out like that
person movie that he made with Stallone
where it's just both of them in prison
and it's not actually a very
action-packed until like the very earth
just dialogue scenes yeah yeah emotional
drama and then you know and then the
actual main action sequence will just be
the same one from and then they CGI Paul
Walker in there and everyone
we all cry guys bill hader and james
mcavoy are in talks to be in it
chapter 2 bill hader is expected to be
taking over the thin wolfhard character
beep-beep Richie which I can totally see
the haters funny and film wolf fart was
funny so it makes sense and James McAvoy
is British is British so makes sense you
take over for Bill
I think the casting for it chapter two
is going to be more exciting than the
actual movie itself I have heard that
the adult portion of the book is kind of
boring and then I watched the miniseries
oh let's say yeah and the adult part is
so boring they go to a Chinese
restaurant for like 20 minutes and they
talk about everything that happens in
chapter one but the thing for me is when
I watched the miniseries I always
thought the Richie Tozier character was
just obnoxious and he was such a hacky
ninety-two Indian and Bill Hader is not
quite as bad but he can kind of be that
way and a lot of instances at least in
my opinion yeah yeah okay he's a little
grating ken has the same thing going on
over and over again but I think it might
actually fit in a weird way I feel like
that and also he does have acting chops
and I feel like that combination could
work in this woods
what's exciting about these two these
guys are like chameleon actors yeah Bill
Hader is like an underrated chameleon
like he does good character work he's
easy documentary he can go in and out
Adorama's too like he is an amazing
actor and James McAvoy what would you
see and do a split arguably he should
have been penny wise and Jessica
Chastain's already was supposed to be
redhead yeah barb barb old barb Oh barb
if the egg cast is the same cast as
stranger things and it's the same cast
as Jumanji welcome to the jungle Jack
Black's is going to be
Ben yeah it's a double dragon reference
opposed to payment bet we can get Tyrese
to play the the one black kid who the
movie didn't really pay any attention to
other one where they gave his plot point
so the fact you can read books like not
mean like good for fat people
representation you see and that's the
worst old heart ever ever but he never
really go gotta go for it cuz the only
does BAM yeah and the thing right you
never heard somebody do with Kevin Hart
impression so you've already set the bar
cuz I can already tell what you're going
is all right tag tag the real rejects in
doubles calm and your impressions of
Kevin Hart send us the Stardust as Kevin
oh this one's fun yeah
Warner Brothers has said [ __ ] you to
Brett Ratner what why because gal gadot
hates him a lot of people do to name
anybody can get [ __ ] done over at the WB
Aquaman's coming out and that will say
that's gonna Jason Momoa will be
astonished by how necessary he is to the
plot of his own field okay so here's
what's going on with this deal guys all
right there's Rat Pack dune
entertainment that Brett Ratner I think
is owner of his name isn't it yeah rat
pack rat rat rat pack Brett Ratner has
been accused of so many bad terrible
sexual deviant things like what well hey
Tower Heist was written by former UCSB
alumni go Gauchos so the last movie
would Rat Pack dude entertainment at WB
they had a 75 picture deal apparently
rampage is gonna be the last one they
were supposed to do some like awful Hugh
Hefner little movie dude really
but they had a whole lot more slated to
be working with and they produce a lot
of the DC EU films as well this is a
huge deal because Brett Ratner will
officially be no.1 now and I guess
that's a good thing
mm-hmm but say goodbye to rush hour for
damn it oh no
because what made rush hour was pret
Ratner's direction yeah it wasn't Jackie
Chan and Chris Tucker you made Chris
Tucker who they are
well Jo Chan was Jackie Chan in China no
he wasn't then China knew Jackie Chan
was already discovered all of his Hong
Kong cinema
oh that's what happens you know remember
our once that was another set I was
expecting there I met him after the
premiere of money talks which start
charlie anyway goodbye Brett Ratner so
long don't make another movie ever again
guys you're never gonna believe this the
live-action Mulan movie is actually
casting Chinese people in their films
what no I'm not gonna clown Atlas this
[ __ ] they're not gonna that one were big
guys is Hawaiian Asian I really was
hoping they would get Cara Delevingne to
play Mulan and that the Emperor would be
played by Jeff Goldblum but apparently
they're getting major superstar Gong Lee
who's not playing with Lana actually
everybody's playing the villain yeah and
gently is gonna be playing the emperor
in it which is cool Donnie Yen is gonna
be playing the commander who mentors
Mulan and with all this information of
Chinese casting I actually can't
remember for the life of me who plays
Mulan in this new movie scroll through
that bad boy yes Liu Yu Fei gonna be
playing and we all know
Liu ye fake as we all follow heavily
Chinese cinema yeah Brett Ratner put her
on and now she's famous everywhere right
this is smart that they're not doing a
whole whitewashing thing I remember when
the Mulan animated movie came out it was
banned in China for a while why because
Chinese people thought it was very
racist and insensitive knowing that and
then read watching Mulan
I dig Wow is
this is really offensive to Chinese
culture actually they might be doing
this old dragon thing yeah this is bad
no the whole from beginning to end like
all the jokes are just like white people
making fun of Chinese people that's what
the script is and I'm really hoping that
they don't do it this time because right
now
Disney is so smart to be out of all
their movies to be adapting Mulan makes
sense because how movies benefits so
much from overseas market especially in
China and then getting a bunch of famous
Chinese actors in there I think we got
to get Jackie Chan in here I can't think
of any other Chinese actors that do
American movies you can get Chun Li back
the lady played chun-li lady played
chun-li she's shield I think oh yeah
she's okay oh she's yeah just never get
that one guy from The Dark Knight with
with the money who they gotta like break
out of China mm-hmm yeah that guy set
him on the stack at the end Michelle
Michelle Kwan yeah cross over you want
to know something interesting about this
though no love interest cast which means
I think they're gonna go like she's just
a warrior and all her strife is gonna be
within that it's not gonna be
referencing that thing oh yeah where she
does it all for a man you know it's
gonna be it's gonna be like a 2018-2019
flipping the roles where it's just a
strong empowered woman and you're gonna
take the lead and there's no guys
involved because you know the mentor
role is Missouri like capitalize on the
female and power stuff why not
capitalize on it ride that wave this
movie is fascinating to me just in the
shape of it cuz I just don't know which
angle to think of it from cuz I'm just
like sup Disney Drive China gonna make
that money oh no this whole thing is a
giant marketing thing that could be
effective and manipulative at the same
time but also this is like so opportune
yeah in every conceivable way we can
craft for whitewash it would pass a
bunch of Chinese people in here that
exact and I have a strong female can be
manipulative but effective yeah so we'll
see I mean at the end of the day our
most movies that are impactful kind of
like that yeah
very much of the now as you get Jesus
water directly I mean it would be very
cool to look at so after Sammy left our
place news about the new Terminator had
dropped we already finished filming with
Sammy so he couldn't be in this part not
diego luna gabriel luna oh wow more
Lunas more Lunas Luna he is going to be
playing apparently the main new
Terminator and the Terminator Tim Miller
James Cameron sequel thingy that's going
on italia Reyes is gonna be playing a
woman from a working-class neighborhood
in Mexico City who finds herself in the
battle between humans and machines in
cool I mean this is awesome that Gabriel
Luna is gonna be a I hear he's great on
Ghost Rider
personally I've never seen any of this
guys work I hear is great and Talia
Reyes I here's a great actress to
personally have never seen any of her
work but this just makes sense I mean
the first couple terminators were white
guys Terminator 3 was a woman Genesis
had an Asian terminator
and now we have a Mexican Terminator
created this guy that's like Mexican
winged how do they like skin these
machines do they really care that much
about the multicultural with their
terminators I have no idea they're
talking about a young woman in a
working-class neighborhood Mexico City
which would make sense because if you
pay attention in Terminator 2 there's a
whole storyline there with Sarah Connor
and John Connor having lived out in a
section in Mexico right and if Linda
Hamilton and Arnold are back in this
maybe they're still hiding out with that
same family
yeah maybe Bob baby's all grown up now
more terminator we'll see it's more
terminated okay I'm glad we got wide
variety of ethnicities in here
I like guaranteed cinnamon I get a Tim
Miller was like we can't just get the
Mexican to play a bad guy we need like
someone who's like a good character
makes the counterbalance the raised
chick yeah yeah yeah there we go she's
Colombian though you know so it'll work
as a Mexican in the movie yeah well
maybe she could be a Colombian living in
South in Mexico City never happen
no it does never happen living elsewhere
from where they're from back to the
outro it's Sammy alright guys well what
movie news of the week did we miss oh
you know what else
Avengers is already gonna dominate the
box office of all superhero movies ever
made but Black Panther just became the
highest-grossing superhero movie in
America knocked that [ __ ] out Black
Panther is also in this movie so Jack
Lee so spin it rolls oh he's gonna be on
a yacht soon a buncha strippers he
already are in the yacht I'm [ __ ]
King [ __ ] people think he's actually
going place an accent he's gonna be on a
yacht named after that purple fly real
is in his forties crazy dude that's
kingly King as they say I don't say this
because I don't think I'm allowed to
black don't crack man but you work at
double toasted calm at least two black
guys yeah subscribe to the regeneration
and if you like black head like a
Mexican and a guy that shows up he's
also got a Mexican it's pretty
multicultural sure you even have a woman
one what one consistent you know you
gotta have that cast member know
Filipinos though dude screw the real
rejects I'm moving to Texas let's do it
you just lost Gertz I'm white I can do
it let's go let's do it real real s
who's leaving to go join double toast
calm
that's the thumbnail right there oh boy